hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're going
to be looking at lesson number two in
our in game study and it's going to be
on triangulation and so many chess games
are won or lost on triangulation I feel
like it's very important to not only
talk about what it is but go over some
examples so you know exactly how it's
played and what triangulation is is it
positioning a chess game where if it's
your opponent's move you will have a
completely winning position but is your
position it's your turn so what you need
to do is use triangulation meaning
you're going to make a triangle with
your kings movements so that you reach
the exact same position or similar and
it's your opponent's move so that's what
we're going to look at today
if you take a look at this example here
the the white King would like to come to
e3 and the black King would like to come
to e5 those are going to be the critical
squares from there the kings can pretty
much control the center and then gobble
up all your opponent's pawns but in this
case it's White's move and if white
tries to capture this e3 square the
black King can come to e5 and right now
it's White's move in this position and
there's nothing good that white can do
we can't come to d3 he can't come to f3
so it's going to be pushed back and once
he does the black King can come to
either d4 or f4 gobble up our pawns and
March his pawn down and promote to a
king so we want to reach this exact same
position but we want it to be blacks
move because if we take a look at it in
this same spot from the very beginning
if it's blacks move black has nowhere to
move at the beginning he can't use
triangulation because if he moves away
we can come to e3
he can't get back to his pawn fast
enough before we control the center he
can't use triangulation his only move is
to come to e5 and if he comes to e5 and
we come to e3 now we have the same
position but it's blacks move and if you
look at the black King he can't go
anywhere you can't come to d5 he can't
come to East six he's going to be forced
back to d6 and now our King can come to
e4 capture and the black King is going
to be further pushed back and we can
continue to march our pawns up and have
complete domination in this game it's
going to be a very easy win from white
so what we need to do from the very
beginning is we need to have this
position but we need it to be blacks
move so what we need to do if it is our
move is we need to use triangulation and
we do that by first not taking the
square that we've won III we first need
to make a triangle and you can come to
d2 or f2 I'm going to move to f2 doesn't
really matter they're both going to make
a triangle and we're going to come to f2
and then try to come to e3 and we'll
take a look at two things that black can
do we already take we already saw that
if as King comes to e5 right away trying
to control the center then our King can
come to e3 and we have this exact same
position as before but as we saw before
it's now blacks move and as we talked
about the black King has no good moves
he's going to have to come back to d6
and once he does once we capture it's
going to be an easy game for white but
if we take a look at the same example
black does have another option it's very
important to look at if the what if the
pawn comes to e3 a lot of players if
black looks at this and really analyzes
and realizes that his King on e5 is a
mistake so we may try and move like III
and from here it would actually be a
mistake for white to capture on e3 even
though black is now down in material his
King can now come to e5 and if you look
at
at it although whites up in material buy
one pawn we have this same position but
now it's White's turn and as we talked
about this is going to be bad for white
white has no way of pushing this black
King up the board black now has the
initiative and why it's going to lose
this game so as we see it would be bad
we really want this position regardless
of that pawn for it to be blacks move so
in this case it would actually be better
for white to bring his King to f3 now
let the pawn can huge push up the board
then we can capture and now if the black
King comes to e5 now we can come to e3
and now it's blacks move so we really
want this position like we talked about
from the very beginning but we want it
to be blacks movement and that's how we
use triangulation we want to create a
triangle in our movements so whether we
reach the exact same position but it's
your opponent's move so we're going to
take a look at a few more examples of
how you can use triangulation in a game
let's go and take a look at this example
and if it's White's move Black's going
to have a completely dominant in winning
game the white rook cannot move to be
one or the pawn can continue to come
down the board to b2 and we have the
same position in the same case this pawn
on do you three can't come to g4 because
the black pawn can then just take it on
g4 and blacks going to have an easy win
in the same way if the white King moves
away from this f3 Square this black King
can come to the g4 Square and have a
completely dominant position depending
on where the King is black and then
pushes pawn to f4 and
after the trade the black king can take
this pawn on e5 or if the king is let's
say on e3 then the black King can just
take on g3 and we'll take what that
looks like here in a minute but if it's
White's move black is going to have an
easy game but it's blacks move so black
has to use triangulation to move to the
same position except now it's going to
be White's turn and so it's going to do
that by first playing h5 it can't come
to f6 because this pawn is here and from
here white has a decision to make and
there's really nothing white can do we
can't move his pawn up to this fourth
ring because of this rook here and he
doesn't want to move his King right away
and we already talked about he can't
move his pawn up so he's going to bring
his rook over to h2 he's going to try to
check our King and make our King move
our King is going to just move back to
g6 and from here the rooks gonna have to
bring his rook back to be to if it
doesn't then black can just bring his
pawn all the way down the board it's
protected by this rook on b4 and he's
going to get a queen why it's going to
have to trade off his rook and he's
going to be down a rook so White's going
to have to bring back his rook to be two
and from here black and play King to g5
and as we can see we have the exact same
position but now it's White's move and
it doesn't matter white moves if he
brings his King to F - G - or even III
they're all going to be bad because now
the black King can come like we talked
about the G for the critical square and
from here blacks next move is going to
be f4 or depending on where the King is
if the King moves let's say that III
where I talked about the King can now
just take on g3 and it's going to be a
fairly easy win for black the King can
then march up the board take this pawn
on e5 he's going to have passed pawns
and he's going
have a fairly easy one once he promotes
to a queen so as you can see in this
example we used our king the white king
didn't move around but we still reach
the exact same position except it was
our opponent's turn and so we gained the
advantage so let's take a look at one
more example in triangulation to make
sure that you completely understand how
it works let's take a look at our last
position and see if you can find the
triangulation from white now hopefully
you found it but so many people in this
position they have a completely winning
in game but they'll try to force the
issue if it's blacks move White's going
to have a fairly easy win but if it's
White's move so many times you'll see a
move widel play pawn to c6 trying to
force the issue but from here black can
come to c8 with his pot with his King
this is going to be a drawn game we can
play it out but so many times white will
waste an opportunity to win because he
doesn't look at it and this from the
starting position white really needs to
use triangulation so you can get the
same position but it's blacks move we
can do that by first playing King to e5
now from here if the King comes though
let's say c6 we can now bring our King
to d4 his King can't come to b5 because
then we can bring our King up to d5 and
basically lock off his King he can't
come back to c6
so once his King can't come to c7 once
he comes back to d7 now our King is
going to come to d5 we have the same
position except now it's blacks move and
now once black brings his King to ca
then we can easily bring our King up the
board and force an easy checkmate so as
you can see here if we can force your
opponent in different situations if they
have no good moves if we can force them
to have the move instead of us using
triangulation this is going to be very
good and always look out for this in
your game if you see your opponent
doesn't have a good move watch out and
see if you can create it to be his move
so
you guys have enjoyed this video if you
haven't already please subscribe I got a
lot of great lessons for the in game
coming up hope you guys enjoy I'll see
you guys next video thanks for watching